when I hit 0l Peru yeah it goes red and
then you can't
the game is on the game is on there
prepare to die all right everything's
working to my side is it working
I may have started that a little too
intense because I got a long way to go
till I catch you but I think I saw you
you'll never find or kill me or I think
I'll exactly find and kill you
I see Teletubby blood on the ground it's
been like two years better and sneakier
oh really is that how you're gonna play
this is that you over there I see I'm
very slow not you at all this is just a
ball on the ground just a ball on the
ground why don't you go kick it around a
little bit while I take all your
custards from you Oh yummy sign it -
Miska speak English
no I was just doing that for your
benefit here's here's my Teletubby
language so what did you just say I said
yummy mess let's hope we have a good
game in it's been a while since we
played this is bringing back a lot of
fond memories of you and me of
vaccarelli days Wow yeah yeah here's
something else on my screen
Oh fine I'm using this yes I do funny
when I don't actually see you so I'm
hoping that something else is scaring
you well I'm just oh you found another
custard yeah the you like out with
lightning constantly hits the floor yes
it's very very nice I love it
dangerous the ambience in this game is
just Spana you know just being totally
honest this is bringing back like a lot
of memories of liquor early times does
it make you feel nostalgia can happy
weird
inside I'm not even joking it really
does because a lot of people don't know
that we've been doing collabs since we
both had like you had 70,000 I had like
30,000 there's something like that we've
been collaborative endeavor gosh yes was
one of the olden days yeah this was like
this was like one of my first million
videos because it was for some reason
yeah I liked it
oh they're louder and clearer you like
launched me up in the air come back here
I like jumped on your head and you like
threw me up in the sky the waters very
good on my Teletubby belly you wanna
watch some Teletubby TV or my Teletubby
Tommy hey thank you you like my name oh
do you know can you even see my name I
stopped to see your name you'll kill me
no no no turn around please please come
on I can't see your name it does not
even say your name oh this is bull
well come back here because I'm gonna
kill you I'm gonna kill you dad Giambi
bash what is your name huh I'm curious
it's Sally O'Malley well that was like
Sally tubby tits oh wow thank you
hey you're a late into these today I've
always been a lady when I play this game
my custard so this custard for me
my custards mmm very nice custard how
are you finding them I have a video that
shows it in the distance kind of thing
oh god damn it I can't see where the
custards are I'm trying to get to you
but you keep pulling away
get back here oh yeah I see oh my god
oh come on I was attacking right when I
was on top of you come back you yummy
mash yamimash I like how you slightly
slow god damn it's not fair stop getting
away so far I just want to be the best
of friends give you one chance you could
give me one chance come on jump in the
water bot okay I will do this are you
think you're a top where'd you go you're
not dying
the Teletubby man spamming everyone
could see that I'm clicking right on him
Oh
telling you you kill me oh you did yeah
ah no that's pure skill everyone will
see on the instant replay that you are
totally horrible in every way and I
snuck up on you and everything okay well
would you like to join the server again
and try to play how about we try one of
the other 20 million maps Oh fine you'll
be the yellow one in this one I want to
kill you okay I love you boy why don't
we why don't we work together against
the Slendy turns over is up is this
gonna be oh the whole thing is just you
trying to kill me yeah that's the idea
we could have we can work together oh I
must destroy you
alright here we go again let the power
go a little
to my head jammy match I already got a
custard so oh god damn it
Yuri behind the real secret is that I
have a heart of gold you just don't want
me to get near you because you're afraid
of me I feel like you're trying to
abduct me by laying these custards
everywhere oh you're like the ice cream
truck driver and you have a trail of
candy leading to the back of your truck
ding ding ding ding
[Music]
you know is doing a face I just know
ending yeah that was kind of terrifying
did you hear that yeah that was not me
that time yeah I mean I'm actually
scared and I'm in the monster Oh God you
gotta come in the fort sometime there
yumminess I've got a delicious custard
here are you waiting by one of the
customs yes you can get all the cats to
give me this one
don't you remember I have a heart of
gold damn ash what are you gonna do to
me when I come see you and get the
custard oh we're gonna have a lot of fun
how about a naked custard bottle a naked
custard battle how about the crying yeah
what is that I'm not too sure wait hang
on there speaking Teletubby
[Music]
Oh yamimash they don't say nice things
about you
I'm sorry they say that you're bad at
the game you're bad at all games and you
should just like quit playing games
altogether they did not just say that
because I actually speak fluent le to me
they just said the markiplier is a big
smelly loser stairs
no come back where'd you go I see you
I'm hiding I'm hiding you're not hiding
very well because I'm special made Oh
where'd you go oh you were looking at me
too long and I'd killed you all right
let's work together let's work together
I'll make a new server together a lot of
fun all right Teletubbies classic it'll
be just like old times but my dad it'll
be such oh I have a camera
help me out a camera ooh I had a camera
oh I saw a kind of a camera in your hand
I thought it was more like a flashlight
but okay I'm just trying to find but
monkey 9 right now there is I see you
hey um I know I'm Sally me I'm Sally
tubby tits yeah this goes play oh yeah
my style I have a nice top hat you do
that is a very nice very nice cowhide
top hat what do I have the same thing oh
boy look through the camera by
right-clicking by the way Oh
what benefit oh I can see custards in
the distance I someone else here
I think suddenly a few of the custards
just disappeared well why did wait what
why is there not fur
what's with the number what number the
number in the top left of the thing well
like maybe Isaac out down when I what
why is that a thing when I hit 0 el Peru
yeah it goes red and then you can be
bash thank you thank you very much Roy
right well I'm dead and I'm recording so
how about we start another one um just
meet on Victorious this time no that
means you're asked aureus
oh you're torte aureus I fine whatever
started again same map cuz that was bull
you you saw him creeping up by me before
you warned me right you saw him coming
up way way long ago I said to you as
long as he was a millimeter behind you
about to kill you that he was behind yes
I own that I probably gave you a
millisecond oh my god join the server
let's get some beers oh oh there is what
are you saying this douche stupidest
Lenny w I've ever seen he just doing
he's standing on the custard he doesn't
want to slam have it I'm gonna go say hi
to him wait maybe this is how they make
the cookies
screams oh he's kind of cute away mommy
why are you wearing no right here come
on around
that's a big heart for love you oh wait
a minute like - I can't live a value
about a new map new map new map Newman
okay I know so that was qualifying it's
being scary house but but monkey eleven
we'll do this one in the secret lair
well I do five Custer's so that we can
actually win how about that
that just means the harder to find
whatever whatever man
we got our secrets we can split up in
whatever who found a custard right here
please Oh got a custard already breath
already got a curse turd I got a curse
turd a Christian you know it's just a
false sense of security
delaying a trap that tricking you making
you feel comfortable and brave Oh get in
the server I'm joining all right oh hey
you tell me those who could sit right at
the spool I hate it I hate it already
without you you didn't save me anything
nope why would I tell me more custard
later that comes out of my Teletubby but
once I'm done with it hey you bought me
up in the air again yeah I like oh all
right heard a mambo oh is that the guy
slow down
that's just the best system light well
as the two tank tip is up there they're
talking to each other there's two tire
bees why don't you go up to them and
run Yami stuff down so stop being such a
baby oh stop being such a baby there's
only two custards left it's gotta be
upstairs we haven't got upstairs yet go
upstairs Yami I can't I spectate so just
spectating what no no no I fell through
the floor did it yummy loving you well
we're bad at this we are pretty bad at
this but we will redeem ourselves over
on your channel right yeah
we're about to redeem ourselves so go
click on yamimash his handsome face over
there for the other part when we beat
this and also he's gonna be the
Teletubby guy so stick toons for that oh
wait no I didn't do Master what am I
talking about Thank You yamimash for
joining me go click on his face if you
want to play more of this or watch us
play more I got back up again I did I
screwed it up back it up again the
breath all right Thank You yamimash for
joining me my problem oh god you can do
that on a less of a delay here Thank You
yamimash for joining me no problem
alright thank you all so much for
watching if you enjoyed this video and
you want to see more go click on Yami
masters fate for the other part where we
play and needs to tell the tubby guy and
also leave a like if you enjoy this
video and as always we will se you
in the next video
[Music]